we have a voicemail number which is two
one nine two david p here is a question
about andrew yang it could actually
apply to many of the candidates running
on the Democratic side right now but
it's about Andrew yang so we will answer
it as such hey Dave them big fan of the
show my question is well you think about
Andrew yang being anti percent and the
and a few polls recently he's a sy
percent in Nevada and five percent in
Arizona do you think this is showing
Mike he is getting up to that five
percent threshold or do you think
they're both outliers or do you think
that they shouldn't be counted for some
other reason Thanks yeah so listen it's
not about those poles being outliers
it's not about they shouldn't be counted
it's just not going to make a difference
okay now because this analysis could be
done for a bunch of the lower-level
candidates I'm gonna do it for Andrew
yang who I like personally and I've
interviewed multiple times because the
caller asked about Andrew yang
nationally Andrew yang is polling at two
point eight percent okay but the primary
is 50 individual state elections plus
some territories so the caller mentions
Nevada
that's the third state to vote it goes
Iowa New Hampshire then Nevada it's true
that you and Rianne voted polled five
percent in one of the four recent polls
now in the other three of four recent
polls he's only polling three percent
but it doesn't matter because there's
something called the fifteen percent
threshold to receive any delegates even
if Andrew yang in Nevada gets fourteen
percent of the vote assuming that there
are other candidates who get 15 percent
or more of the vote
Andrew yang doesn't get any delegates
right he gets 0 delegates so his 5
percent in Nevada or his 3 percent
aren't going to get him any delegates
that's just the way it works right it's
not my opinion that's just the way it
works then you go to Arizona it's true
there is a poll out of Arizona where
Andrew yang has 5% now Arizona doesn't
vote until March 17th and there's a
whole bunch of states that will have
already voted
but again ignoring that there's a 15
percent threshold that has to be met if
yang gets his 5 percent of the vote in
Arizona
in almost every circumstance he gets
zero delegates so I'm not trying to bust
anyone's bubbles I'm just wondering if
some people don't know the primary
process and how that threshold works
because once you recognize that 3 or 5%
it doesn't actually make a difference in
helping him to secure the Democratic
primary nomination nomination now if you
understand that but you still believe
that there's a path then I want to hear
from you I want to hear what that path
is we've got a great bonus show for you
today we will talk about McDonald's
firing their CEO for a relationship he
had with an employee we will talk about
Apple pledging billions of dollars to
fight the California housing crisis and
much more get instant access to the
bonus show instant takes under a minute
by signing up at join pakman.com or by
becoming a patron at patreon.com slash
david pakman show